Netflix has rapidly become a ubiquitous
part of nearly all of our lives with its
incredibly deep constantly shifting
streaming catalog of movies and
television series usually the phrase
there's something for everyone is mere
hyperbole but not in the case of Netflix
which absolutely has something for you
whether you're a fan of extreme horror
an actual toddler or anything in-between
of course with such an extensive
selection there's bound to be some
content that's a bit problematic whether
it's the material itself the
production's background or inappropriate
scenes Netflix has put up a surprising
amount of material that's drawn
controversy for one reason or another
here's a look at some of Netflix's most
controversial offerings 13 reasons why
when 13 reasons why they viewed in 2017
it immediately became a lightning rod
for controversy
the story picks up after high schooler
Hannah Baker takes her own life leaving
behind a series of cassette tapes that
details the reasons for her actions via
flashbacks the show depicts disturbing
instances of assault bullying and
Hannah's own final moments
despite its seemingly self-contained
premise the series was picked up for a
second season providing a fresh round of
controversy in 2018 the new episodes
more problematic scenes include an
explicit depiction of a young man's
assault by another man an incident that
nearly prompts a school shooting
to its credit Netflix has added content
warnings before every episode there's
also now a companion series beyond the
reasons to encourage discussions of the
issues the show presents but some
continue to label it as mere
exploitation blue is the warmest color
2013 French drama blue is the warmest
color won the Palme d'Or at the Conn
Film Festival despite drawing
controversy for its shockingly graphic 7
minute long lesbian love scene comments
from lead actress
adèle exarchopoulos and Lea save you
concerning the film's production and
director Abdul Latif kashia's reaction
to them have only added to the
controversy in a Daily Beast interview
XR Cooper listens they do praise cassis
is a genius but they also called the
making of the film
horrible
insisted that neither would do work with
him again with Sidhu saying in America
we'd all be in jail hashish then took
his stars to task for their comments
even threatening to take them to court
the film is undeniably brilliant but
with this context it's tough not to see
it's more demanding scenes in a new
light a typical building a wacky sitcom
around a main character with
high-functioning autism is nothing if
not tricky atypical has its heart in the
right place but it also hits every
stumbling block along the way it can be
forgiven for failing to put together a
complete and accurate picture of the
condition as there are far too many
variations along the spectrum for one
character to embody them all but some
have taken the show to task for
attempting to play up the condition for
Laughs
while still failing to be insightful or
funny I'm doing research on how to steal
a woman and Bayley is the perfect test
subject because she's a skank outlets
like Huffington Post and Salon have
slapped the show with labels ranging
from stereotypical to offensive creator
robia Rashid and her team have also
inspired criticism for failing to
consult any actual autistic people but
the series seems to have found its
fanbase as Netflix has renewed it for a
second season perhaps with a little
course correction it can become the
shining example of mainstream
representation that the autism community
was hoping for for now it's just more of
this bazinga love Gaspard inouye seems
to live to provoke controversy the mind
behind such famously challenging
cinematic experiences as enter the void
and irreversible no way used his 2015
film love to tell the fairly simple
story of the birth life and death of a
romantic relationship but no way being
the way he told it in a fashion that's
anything but simple specifically he
included unstimulated lovemaking and
shot it all in three B in case you were
wondering yes there is an explosive shot
that takes full advantage of the 3d
format no God please no no it's a
supremely silly moment and what is
otherwise a rather serious and ground
critics generally agree that love was
underwhelming self-indulgent and
strangely unerotic even so without a
doubt the closest thing you'll find a
hard core content on Netflix if that's
your thing we're not judging bigmouth
Netflix is generally fared quite well
with its original animated offerings
with titles like Bojack horseman and
athis for family soaking up critical
acclaim despite their adult themes in
humor but with big mouths they took a
considerable risk an examination of
puberty the show leans heavily on
vulgarity and gross-out humor while some
critics have found it to be sharp funny
and engaging others have deemed its
utter commitment to nastiness a bridge
too far the criticism ranges from
supposed confusion over whether the show
is aimed at children to its alleged
liberal agenda and sideways references
to homosexuality and pedophilia the
series has also managed to draw ire for
casting Jenny slate a white actress as
the voice of a black character but
despite all of the brouhaha the first
season was a significant hit with
viewers Netflix will be back with more
for season 2
so did you guys hear the news
nymphomaniac professional provocateur
Lars von Trier's nymphomaniac arrived in
two feature-length volumes it's the
story of a woman recounting her
devastating romantic history to a
seemingly sympathetic older man after
she's brutally beat nymphomaniac is not
so much titillating as it is
psychologically uncomfortable of course
it's the love making scenes that stirred
up the most controversy causing the film
to be banned in multiple countries but
if it's a Rada sysm you're looking for
you won't find it here nymphomaniac is
an unforgiving portrait of how its main
characters compulsions inevitably ruin
her life and the lives of nearly
everyone she comes into contact with and
sadly there's no redemption to be found
it's jaw-dropping ending the push
Netflix's original special the push
stars English Mentalist Darren brown who
wowed viewers with a viral video in
which he demonstrated the seeming
ability to literally put thoughts into
people's heads this involved convincing
actor Simon Pegg that he had always
wanted a red BMX bike as a child what's
going on what's my name
he's gonna be in a pickle jail by 2:00 I
know it but in the push he enlists the
help of over 70 actors to attempt to put
a very different kind of idea into the
mind of an unsuspecting mark the actors
guide an ordinary man named Chris
through a series of increasingly bizarre
situations ultimately Chris must decide
under intense pressure whether to push
another man from the top of a tall
building Brown isn't actually trying to
get Chris to commit murder just to
convince him of the idea but that's a
distinction that walks a very fine line
between bizarre prank and psychological
torture chris is enmeshed in
web of lies and that's important I need
him to feel like there's only one way
out when he's told to commit murder the
paperboy 2012's the paperboy is the kind
of quirky tonally challenged film that
might have come and gone and limited
release with few having noticed despite
the presence of bankable stars Nicole
Kidman Matthew McConaughey and Zac Efron
though it features stylish direction
from Lee Daniels this melodramatic
thriller is kind of a mess and mostly
unmemorable except for one truly weird
scene after Efron suffers a jellyfish
sting Kidman attempts to alleviate the
pain by urinating on it and that may not
even be the film's most disturbing scene
thanks to the bizarre prison hanky-panky
between Kidman and John Cusack but it's
not just every day that you get to see
major movie stars peeing on each other
and that was pretty much all anyone
could talk about leading up to the
film's release I don't know what I
expected stepsister's Netflix's
acquisition of stepsisters a topical
exploration of race on college campuses
from dear white people leader chuck
hayward and master of nuns lina wait
seemed like a no-brainer but the movies
central premise in which a black college
senior is tasked with teaching a bunch
of disgraced white sorority sisters to
step sparked controversy before it even
debuted the film's creators have taken
issue with stepsisters being
pigeon-holed as a cultural appropriation
comedy weaith has pointed out that it
has a high degree of self-awareness and
that culture is meant to be appreciated
and explored by everyone many critics
have also panned the film for the more
conventional crimes of awkward plotting
recycled tropes and dull dialogue at a
time when race relations is a hot topic
in the United States it seems unlikely
that anyone involved in the production
could have failed to foresee the flap
that it would cause white girl writer
director Elizabeth wood leaned on a
couple of very specific influences for
her 2016 indie film white girl writer
harmony Korean and director Larry
Clarke's 1995 provocative kids and her
own past as a hard-partying girl from
the Midwest attending college in New
York white girl is concerned with
matters of power and control as
fresh-faced protagonist
Leigha loses both as she delves deeper
into a lifestyle of illicit drugs casual
relationships after the film's debut at
the sundance film festival Wood was
accused of playing to the exploitation
crowd in order to shoulder her way into
Hollywood in an interview with vogue she
responded by saying it's interesting to
me that sexuality upsets people more
than talking about race or privileged or
gender
[Music]